the raiders received some bad news when
defensive lineman gerald mccoy left the
first game with a season-ending injury
today the situation got even worse john
treach has the very latest news from the
silver and black hey john hey there
kirsten gerald mccoy has suffered major
injury setbacks the last two years it's
hard enough to heal his body now the
raider lineman must repair his
reputation the nfl has suspended mccoy
for six weeks without pay for use of a
banned performance enhancing substance
mccoy left the first game against the
ravens on a cart he suffered a
season-ending knee injury a year after
rupturing his quad muscle and missing
the 2020 campaign but now adversity
oh it gets larger with the cloud of
performance-enhancing drugs mccoy can
serve the ban while on injured reserve
this season he just will miss six game
checks from his one-year 1.25 million
dollar deal mccoy responded on twitter
this afternoon i love the game of
football and have nothing but respect
for the players fans and this league
i've given my all to this game and
worked my entire career to compete train
and rehabilitate at a high level with
integrity it is with great
disappointment that i recently learned i
tested positive for a banned substance
something i was prescribed to take to
help with scar tissue and tendon
strength from a previous injury in no
way would i ever intentionally take
anything to help with performance or
gain a competitive advantage this was an
honest mistake but it's something i take
full responsibility for i apologize to
my family the nfl my teammates and the
fans and ask humbly for your forgiveness
mccoy is 33 with an impressive resume
borderline hall of famer and loyal
falling between both fans and former
teammates but it's the way of the world
players are ultimately accountable for
everything they put into their bodies